Before we get into any crazy
multi-project Android builds,
we should talk about how to figure out
what's going on when your build fails.
While it's technically possible
to attach a debugger to Gradle
if you really know what you're doing,
the first line of defense should
really be thorough logging.
Gradle logs messages
in one of six levels.
Debug spews a ton of, only occasionally,
useful information on
Gradle's internal workings.
Info gives much better insight
into what Gradle is up to.
It details how long each
task takes to complete, and
other high level events,
like when Gradle connects to its Daemon.
Lifecycle logs what tasks are currently
being run, as well as the total time
the build took, and whether or
not it was successful.
Quiet is the level for log messages,
that should be this way
even if the user has told Gradle to be
quiet, but there aren't any errors.
Also, any print line statements
in the build scripts
are actually redirected
to the quiet log level.
Finally, error is exactly
what it sounds like.
By default, Gradle displays all logs
at the lifecycle level and above.
Running with the -d flag,
gives all logs at the debug level or
above, which is all of them.
The -i flag, gives all logs
at the info level and above.
And finally,
-q gives only quiet and error logs.
Remember again that println
statements are equivalent to
the quiet logging level.
This means that even if
the user uses the -q option,
println statements will
still appear in the log.
When the Gradle build
script fails to complete,
it doesn't display
the stacktrace by default.
If you want to see the stacktrace,
gist of your code, use the stacktrace
option or the -s flag.
To see the entire stacktrace,
including Gradle core code,
you can use the -full-stacktrace option,
or a capital S.
Again, make sure the difference
between these two is that
the partial stack trace is a lowercase
sand the full stack trace uppercase S.